all right so it looks like
this morning's been a morning of stack
based languages
i have another stack based offering
my name is clayton bauman and i'm the
author of the babel programming language
today i want to explain to you how bible
works as well as to demonstrate
the language to you using the reference
implementation
that i've been developing i began
developing babel
around 2006
there had been revelations in 2005 that
the nsa was routinely
spying on u.s citizens at that time many
privacy rights observers were
concerned that those revelations were
just the tip of a much larger
top-secret iceberg and in the last few
months
we've gotten a better idea of just how
large that iceberg really is
what is the connection well the security
flaws
which we now know that nsa introduced
into many
devices and protocols which we all use
were made possible in large part by a
flawed legal model
of property rights in these devices
on free software proprietary hardware
digital rights management
and government backdoors make possible
malicious features that are opposed to
the rights
of the user in his or her device
i want to assert that today we have an
inordinate focus on the rights of the
designer
in his or her design and this is
particularly
particularly true in software where the
product is the design
instead i believe we need to shift our
focus to the rights of the device owner
in the use of his or her device and this
is the message that richard stallman
has been repeating to the world for
decades in regards to
free software
babel is a general-purpose high-level
language and you might wonder what these
lofty political and ethical concerns
have to do
with designing a programming language
and my view is that they have everything
to do with it
if i truly own my android or my iphone
or my windows 8 laptop then i should
have every right to crack open the case
change out the bios but whatever
software i want to run on it
but if all manufacturers can and do
dictate to me that i will use the
software that is pre-installed
on their device whether or not i trust
that software
then all devices become vulnerable to
this widespread security failures
which we have learned just a couple
weeks ago the nsa and gchq have posted
on the digital community
babel 1.0 will use public key
cryptography to permit the interpreter
to check whether a given piece of code
is permitted to run locally this changes
the way of thinking about rights and
executing code on a device
rather than asking what software is this
device
permitted to run we're asking
what software do we trust to have access
to this valuable devices
data resources and execution
capabilities
now to be clear uh code authentication
is not a magic cure to security flaws in
the underlying platform
if the underlying platform is insecure
then the
interpreter cannot possibly hope to be
secure
however a large community of users can
push proprietary platform vendors
to get with the program that is open up
their designs to verification
and thus become trustworthy and even
though i've talked quite a bit about
security concerns i want to emphasize
that babel is not a domain specific
security language
rather babel 1.0 is a general purpose
language
with a large set of security primitives
built in as operators in the language
as well as the interpreter will be able
to perform cryptographic
authentication to permit remote code
execution
so despite my nervousness i want to jump
into the details of the babel language
and then give you a demo
uh so you can see babel in action
so the preliminaries are that babel is a
general purpose
high-level language it is a stack based
language
as i mentioned earlier it's so that
means we're in post-fix order
so instead of saying the more familiar
you know var equals one plus two we're
saying
you know put var on the stack then put
one on the stack put two on the stack
perform the plus operator to add the one
and the two and then perform the set
operator to put three
result into var babel is not pure
many operators can have side effects and
babel is untyped this is probably the
most controversial part is
is being on type but we do have tags
which allow us to keep track of
types if you want to
so the the babel data structure is
called the b struct or for babel struct
it's the underlying container for all
data in a babel program
and uh data such as strings integers
unsigns floats are all stored as values
in leaf arrays and no pointers can be
stored in a leaf array so
that's one kind of thing is the leaf of
a leaf array
ordinary pointers are stored in interior
arrays
every pointer in an interior array must
be initialized and valid
a valid pointer is a pointer that points
at the first entry
of either a leave array an interior
array or a tag pointer which i'll
mention in a moment
and no values can be stored in an
interior array
a tagged pointer is a pointer with an
associated 128-bit hash value called a
tag
so these three items here the leaf array
the interior array and the tag
tagged pointer are what define the be or
what compose the elements that can pro
pose a b
struct and a b struct has a single
root pointer all right so to
associate syntax with uh what's
being encoded internally uh this is a
fairly low level view we're actually
looking at what
are the words if if you're a 32-bit
machine this would be 32-bit word so if
your 64-bit machine would be 64-bit
words
what are the words we're actually
compiling this is almost like a bytecode
view
if we say val on the left and give three
hex values i used hex because the
dumping operator dumps out the view of
memory in hex
so we can visually correlate it give it
three values we're gonna get an array of
three values if we say pointer and give
it
a list of three values
we're going to get an array of three
pointers pointing at single
value arrays
pointers unlike values can be nested
pointer arrays or or interior arrays as
i called them
and here on the top line you can see an
example where we have a pointer to the
value ace
and then the remaining points at some
more pointers
which is equivalent to the list syntax
shown below so
both of these will produce the same
memory image which you can see
illustrated with with the picture here
the interior arrays or pointer eraser
encoded in green and the value arrays
are encoded in blue for differentiation
and then the tagged pointer which i
mentioned last item
is basically a way to take some
string description and associate it with
us with a pointer and
here we have a tag uh statement and foo
being the the string that we're going to
hash we're going to convert it to 128
bit hash
and then we're going to point to
whatever comes after that so in this
case we've taken a
foo we've hashed it and it's now
pointing at the list that i illustrated
to you before so you can see in this
slide
all three elements together the tag the
interior array and leaf array
and then this is the uh code statement
shown uh in the sparse syntax i'll
mention that a little bit
and here's you can see that code is data
in babel which
is um nice because we can just put
anything we want into a code statement
and it will be
um assembled by the the parser
compiled by the parser and then to
emphasize that babel is untyped here
i've shown two different syntaxes
that compile to the exact same thing so
if we have val and you give the string
hello you're going to get these
ascii bytes out shown on the right
and if you take the same hex bytes and
you say val and give those hex bytes
it's going to give the same thing
okay so the underlying virtual machine
or the the bv and babel virtual machine
is stored in a b-structure as a b-struct
it consists of three stacks it has a
down stack
an up stack and a managed stack which is
a hat tip to
chuck more named it rstack
codelist is implemented as a linked list
and it contains data operands
and code or operators or a mix of both
in reality
and that's pointed to by the code
pointer every data operand as it's
encountered in the code stream it's
pushed onto the d-stack
for later operation and then there's a
kind of stack nesting i think
it's unique to babel using these
operators like call up and down we can
avoid
some of the need to rotate and do other
things to the stack
with these operators conditional
looping and other operators that
manipulate code pointer
utilize the r stack and the symbol table
contains all symbols and these are the
primary elements that
are going to make up your babel virtual
machine
your bbm so the runtime or babel
interpreter
actually has a small bootstrap and it's
itself written
in babel um and it loads your pro babble
program for you and you can inspect
these
three files here in the source directory
to see um how that's done
actually you know when i run the make
script it's going to take these babble
files and it's going to
write a c file out and then compile that
together with the babel
interpreter it maintains a cache copy of
the most important pointers
to avoid needless traversal of the bvm
for example codepointer is you're
executing your code you don't want to be
uh starting from the root pointer of
your your virtual machine traversing
through to the code point so we actually
maintain a cache of that internally
there's a jump table that permits of one
vectoring to built-in
operator functions we just have a
function pointer array
the op codes index into that array and
we jump to the function we want to
execute and then there's uh the the
interpreter is also responsible for
command line capture
pulling in the arg fees standard in
environment variable capture etc
okay the reference implementation is
written in c
it has a pearl wrapper front end right
now that generates the native babel
binary forming and a little
pearl script called sparse.purl which
stands for s expression parse
and it has a minimal syntax for the
immediate value so we can take
everything
and compile it into the babel virtual
machine
code and then optimizations will begin
after i get to babel 1.0 someday
okay so here's a big picture a visual
view
of what i just explained to you it's a
little bit small on the screen i
apologize but
on the left we have sort of the world
out there we have i o between the babel
interpreter which is depicted as the
code
or the little cloud there in the center
and then above and below that we have
the up stack and the down stack which
allows us to move up and down the stack
i'll illustrate that to you with a demo
as well as we have a symbol table to
keep track of uh symbols
persistent symbols the code stream going
off to the right and then the r stack to
manage our
control flow transfers as well as mass
storage for file
file accesses uh what is the future of
babel so i'll have a built-in parser at
some point for a syntax that i'm calling
bipedal
which will be kind of excuse me a
superset of the s par
syntax that we have right now which is
kind of everything has to be written in
s
expressions um i'll have a wider wide
selection of crypto primitives built in
from the libtom crypt as i mentioned in
the introduction
and it will also be linked with uh lib
crawl so that we can pull in
and access the web you know web get
input
bzip2 so we can actually have some
compression operators to just
work right in with the language as well
as graph is
i hope to link that in i'll actually
have that as part of the demo
so that we can actually see what is
going on inside the interpreter
and i hope to get it compiling on gcc
and mingw
in the future right now compiles on tcc
which is not widely used
compiler and i expect to make it
cross-platform compatible on windows and
starnext platforms to start with
we'll have also additional built-in
operators which are not currently
in i have about 250 operators right now
will probably
top off around 300 or so at 1.0
okay so the the media the presentation
that i want to get to is
just sort of to demo uh babel to you
i apologize my screen is a little bit
narrower on the presentation display so
there may be a little bit of crowding
as we switch back and forth between the
the demo view and the command line
okay so
all right so let's say we wanted to um
write a hello world
we're going to actually do some live
code editing
i just wanted to up the pressure here
and
bigger uh
well i won't be doing it here so um let
me see what
what it looks like in vim
is that readable
okay well let's see if we can do it
all right so i'm going to create main i
hope that's readable
um at least in the back i apologize if
it's not readable
um so first we're going to create a
list here main put main in it and we'll
say hello world and we've
now have a string we're going to print
the string out this is very
very scary very difficult stuff here
and let's see if it works
okay there we go we got a hello world
okay and then
let's add some numbers together we can
do some other interesting things
very difficult complex things like
adding some numbers together
again we're post fix order so this will
be 2 2 plus
and that should give us 4. we'll convert
it to
ascii form and then we'll add a new line
and we'll print
it out
okay let's see what we get here
and we got hello world and two plus two
does it in fact equal four
let's see what else can we do we can
make a list of names here
and some good names here these are good
names
and let's say we wanted to print these
out each one on its own line so we'll
give a new line
and we'll print it out and then we just
say each which is a lot like a map
operator
that was mentioned earlier
and let's run this and see what we get
all right looks good we got a name
sprinting out here in the back
uh for the people in the back it is
actually working
if you trust me and then
what else could we do let's see let's
try some three
random numbers and these will actually
be
in an array so we'll say each array so
we're going to
print out each element in the array and
let's make them between
0 and 99 so we'll do remainder
and it's you know reverse order because
we're stack
based here then we'll convert to ascii
we'll add a new line and we'll print it
out
so we should hopefully get three random
numbers in addition
there we go very good and now let's say
for just
no reason at all we just want to do all
of this stuff three times
so we go ahead and put everything in a
code list and we just say
three times
and then we'll actually give some space
here so we can see
we run it and there we go we've
printed everything out here same as we
had before
but three times and the numbers
generated are random i'm using mercen
twister
for the random number generator okay so
what is going on underneath the hood
what what is actually
in hello dot sp
once it gets compiled by the by the uh
parse script so let's actually i have
another uh
demo program which i want to show you
bstr.sp and what this is actually going
to do is it's going to
pull in on the command line whatever we
give on the command line it's going to
read it read the file and i just called
that operator slurp in honor to
pearl slurping we're going to load it
which is actually
taking the array of bytes that we read
in or actually words and then making
them live
in the babel program and then we're just
going to do this magic little thing
i called display here which is going to
pull it up and display the view for us
so let's run that
and dot sp and we'll run it on the hello
world program that we were just taking a
look at at a moment ago
um hello sp dot bbl
which is the compiled version of it
whoops you can't actually run that have
to run babel
and let's give it a moment to process
so what this actually shows that this is
a view
of everything that is in and i know
that's too small to read but i'll just
zoom out so you can get a view of the
scope of of the hello.sp so after
hello.sp which is everything that we
were just
editing uh live on screen a moment ago
has been parsed by the parsdot or
spars.perlscript
it spits out the bytecode and once we
read the bytecode in
in babel this is actually what it looks
like and you can see
the various elements there here's the
hash uh hash
excuse me the tag pointers the interior
arrays and leaf eraser are depicted here
with the bold boxes
okay and we'll take a look at a couple
more
after this first i want to show what is
going on
in the stack because we have
um you know in a stack based language
we're operating on the stack all the
time so
what is actually going on in the stack
so we have
two three four and five just three or
four excuse me uh operating values we're
gonna push these onto the stack
then we're gonna put the stack pointer
itself on the stack and we're going to
display
what does the stack look like so
demo slash ud stacks sp
all right so we're going to run this and
hopefully we see
something like what we expect to see in
the stack so
here we have uh the two the three the
four and the five and you can see
five is on the top of the stack it's the
last thing that we pushed onto the stack
these zeros here are kind of a stack
indexing metadata
which will have tag tags associated with
them later on
it's unimplemented so just ignore those
all right so
the up and down operators which i
mentioned earlier
mysterious operators i'll just show you
how those work to help simplify stack
usage so
i'll just the easiest way to explain it
is to do it so two three four
five and then we're going to move down
the stack one
so we'll rerun here and see what does
our stack look like after doing
a down
okay so now we just have two three and
four on the stack and what we've done is
we just removed
the five off the stack and let's see how
do we get
how do we get the five back onto the
stack as well obviously we use the up
operator
to get the five backup on the stack so
let's rerun there and take a look at
what we get
helps to go over here okay so now the
five is back on the stack so
two three four down back up we've got
our
our uh five back so essentially the up
and down
operators are just implementing
a second stack which is what the u stack
is for so we'll take a look at the u
stack
after we've done only a down and not an
up so we're gonna do two three four five
move down and let's take a look at
what's on the u stack and hopefully we
see there
what we expect to see
and for some reason it's not popping up
now and there's our five
so the five was just moved over to the
use stack saved over
temporarily okay
all right the next thing to show is the
symbol tables
so we'll take a look at take a look at
the symbol table
um
okay so i've prepared a little program
here that's just going to
first time we're going to do two things
first we're going to do program a and
then we'll do program b
program a we're going to put the pointer
for the symbol table
on the stack and then we're going to
just display it and see what's in the
symbol table
whoops hold on typos
okay
and this one will take a moment to
process it appears that there's nothing
here
there is actually something here it's
just fairly big
so just got to zoom out and here's
a view of everything in the symbol table
right now so why is there so much stuff
in the symbol table we weren't putting
it in the symbol table
we're pulling in the environment
variables and this this big guy hanging
right here
all of that that's our environment
variable been
read in okay so the next
uh thing that i want to show you on that
symbol tables we'll run program b now
and what this is just going to do is say
let's look up the symbol environment and
this operator is just a development
operator it's actually going to go away
fairly soon but let's look up the env
symbol
and then let's look up path in that
let's print it out
so i'll run rerun that command
and we should see this time there we go
so we've printed out the path variable
we've read it in from the environment
yay complicated stuff all right so
um what else
let's take a look at hashes or hash
tables
um
oops
we have the we have arrays
arrays of values arrays of pointers we
have lists
what i haven't shown is the hash tables
which are you know
responsible for implementing the symbol
table
i will not be able to show both of these
together because the screen has been
made narrow
but here we have you know a list of
plural animal names in their groups you
know like you usually see in a textbook
we're going to do is actually i'm going
to change this
right here okay we're going to
take this list of lists and then i wrote
a little
bit of snippet of code here called make
cache which is actually
in the same file down here make cache
and what makehash does is it
declares a new hash for us and then
iteratively inserts all those elements
into the hash
for us so i'm going to make the hash and
then we're going to
perform some lookups in the hash so
um
sp okay so this part i apologize
if you can't see down at the bottom but
if i type you know
eagles it gives me irie which is the
plural i guess for
eagles and then trout oops it's going to
crash
if you'd miss type
if we type trout we get uh hover
and so on and so forth cattle we should
get heard
right so it's looking up in the hash um
all right so the next thing i want to
show you is
loops or error control or float flow
controls excuse me
so let's take a quick look at loops
okay so i have various loops we have we
can do
uh times we can do uh loops
loop loop which is loops and definitely
do while loop
and then i'm going to do a demo of a
cartesian
product with two nested loops um
i'll just so what what i'm showing here
is i'm taking that same list of lists
construct that i had before mapping the
strings into the hash and
i've just mapped in pointers to the code
snippets themselves
so it's actually a hash that you know is
pulling up code for us
and then we can eval the code and this
little
uh exclamation mark guy here is my
clever way of saying eval is just
shortening it's like do it you know
imperative
um so
let me just illustrate loops so we do
purl
babble demo slash oops.sp
and we'll do a we'll say loop and that's
going to look up the code for
loop loop for us and i say 10 times
okay so 10 times it runs this sub
program for us that pulled up using the
hash
and uh iteratively prints out the stars
it's counting up from
zero because loop operator goes
indefinitely so just counts up zero one
two three four five
and so on if we wanted to do
a times loop instead we can say times
here to this little demo program it's
going to go and look up in the hash for
us
and it's going to do it 10 times and
this time we'll see that the stars are
counting down that's because the times
operator operates on a countdown 109.87
until it
gets to zero okay and then i'll just
quickly demo the
cartesian product and this one i'm going
to turn down from ten to three
because you get square and this
just illustrates we get three three
three two three one two three two two
two one and so on and so forth
um and that's just implemented using
this nice little operator
here see if i can show it
this iter operator and what the iter
operator does is it goes and and pulls
whatever current
iteration count i'm on so that you have
access to that
which is better than i think than you
know c4 loop where
you have to manually track it
okay so uh the next thing i want to take
a look at is
copying
which i think is a very important point
a lot of the
stack operators in babel are inspired by
joy
i think joy is a very beautiful language
i'm sure a lot of people here agree
unfortunately it's not being developed
further with the passing of
fontan but here we have a list of lists
uh containing characters and we're going
to put them on the stack
and then we're going to dupe it and then
we're going to display the stack as
we've done before
and we'll just take a look at what does
that look like
does it look like what we expect it to
look like
maybe maybe not okay so i'll just zoom
out a little bit here
and what we see here is
this is the stack view might be a little
bit confusing this is the top of the
top element to the stack right here and
this is the top of stack minus ones the
next thing down on the stack
and what you see is that they're both
pointing at this very same list of lists
here and here's our list of lists
depicted for us with all the cons boxes
a little bit
uh busy but i think we can see what's
going on there and then by contrast
let's take a look if we change this
dupe operator we change this to copy
and now we're going to rerun what
changes
all right so the view here
is a little different now here's our top
of stack top of stack minus one but
instead of pointing
at the same items in memory we actually
have two full copies in memory
of the list of lists that we created to
begin with so
uh the copy operator just does a by
value copy for you
in place and very efficient
copying of and this can be applied to
arbitrarily large
data structures
okay so uh let's take a look at
unload demo now so the unload operator
in babel
um it's kind of half of copy
and what it does is it takes a you know
a list of lists we're going to create
this hash
out of it and we're going to unload that
hash what's actually going to serialize
the whole data structure into a single
array
and then we're going to come down here
we're going to spit it out to this file
demo.unload.babel
so i've serialized the whole data
structure and i'm going to put it into
file
so let's run it pearl and it won't
actually do anything very
interesting it'll pop up and show us
okay so this is the these are the first
few bites of the
the array being depicted there so you
can see it and
i can't again i apologize for the screen
being a little too
narrow but we'll take a look at that
file
that got dumped out so we'll look at the
hex values here and we'll just scroll
up to the top one and you'll see that
here that the the first
two 16-bit words are zero which we would
expect here given the display we've been
given uh the next 16-bit word is bfe8
which is the lower half here
and 93.5 which is the upper half here
it's kind of a little indian
of course intel and continuing on from
there so we can see that
you know these bytes have been spit out
exactly as we expected into
file so the other half we want to look
at
is the um the load
operator which kind of undoes unload so
now what we're going to do with
here with this demo is we're going to
actually open the
file that we just put out we're going to
pull it in
and we're going to x you know invoke the
load operator on that to make that
data structure live in memory
so
okay so what we've done in and we're at
that same prompt that we had before with
the hash demo
um sp and it's asking for a key
if i type in for example cattle it comes
back and says heard
if i type eagles you know say i re trout
you know say hover
and so on and so forth uh geese should
give
gaggle and what's different about this
uh time running is that instead of
getting the hash
you know have written out the hash in
this sp file
what's actually done is it's pulled in
the serialized version
from that unload.bbl loaded it into
memory and now we're able to operate on
the hash
that we've loaded from file
okay and now i'll give my final demo and
then take
questions and answers
okay so i have a little program here
that i called babble.sp
and what it's going to do is take
whatever we give it on the command line
it's going to slope it
pull it in slurp it in load it it's
going to print dream
then it's going to execute what we
pulled in from the command line the the
excuse me the file that we pulled in and
it's going to print dream again
so we'll say babel demo slash
babel.sp demo inception.sp.bbl
and it prints dream within a dream so
let's take a look
quickly at what is in inception.sp
and we'll see within here so what has
happened is we've actually
pulled in a babel program that was
earlier compiled
we've loaded it and then after printing
dream executed it
returned and printed the dream again
that's all i have take questions